[Música]
han formado algo
yo sé muchas veces yo recuerdo la
primera vez que lo hice cuando tenía 6
años agarré mi carrito de control le
quité las pilas lo desarme para
separarlo en dos partes
y dentro puede ver esa placa verde con
circuitos que tanto tengo grabada en mi
memoria
la arranque los motores y los conecta
pilas solamente para verlos girar
y gracias a que desarmaba todo lo que
llega a mis manos mis papás yo no sabían
si comprarme más juguetes o unas esposas
para que dejara de hacerlo
programa di cuenta que desde ese momento
en el que desarma salgo por primera vez
comienzas a armar un mejor futuro
primero la curiosidad y esta te lleva a
hacer experimentos cuando comencé
conectaba cables sin sentido me quemé me
explotaron algunas cosas pero comenzó a
comprender cómo funcionaba todo
recuerdo alguna vez haber leído cómo
funcionaban las pilas pero hasta que lo
lleve a la práctica realmente lo entendí
conecte un led a una pila de 15 voltios
y por si muchos no lo saben el benjamín
de 6 años tampoco lo sabía
el pequeño ley de explota pero adivinen
quién nunca más volvió a conectar un led
a una pila de 15 voltios pues yo
y así fue como aprendí a diseñar
circuitos armar cosas ya construir
robots con prueba y error
y aunque muchas veces los robots no
hacen nada o cuando los prendía en vez
de empezar a moverse sacaban humo cosas
que no tienen que hacer
no me desanima va y lo sigue intentando
hasta lograrlo como cuando hice mi
primer robot de pelea un mini sumo un
robot que tienen que sacar a su oponente
de la arena de combate fue todo un reto
porque imaginen tener que meter tres
sensores dos motores una pila y una
placa de control en un espacio de 10 x
10 centímetros
para empezar la pelea era un problema
enorme pues no podía poner una muy
grande por el espacio pero tampoco una
muy pequeña porque no le daría la
potencia suficiente al robot
pero tras ya haber aprendido por un par
de explosiones cómo funcionaban las
pilas y cómo manejarlas correctamente lo
solucione al final logré hacer el robot
aunque tengo que admitir les era
bastante feo
tenía cables por fuera telecom de un
lado con la loca del otro como el que
van a ver ahorita en pantalla
como pueden ver no era muy bonito ese
robot me encantaba
y pues gracias a este robot y a otros
que cada vez fueron mejores tuve la
oportunidad de ir a dos competencias en
la primera creo que le dio miedo a mis
robots pues se quedó inmóvil ante sus
combates pero justo terminando la
competencia empezó a moverse el
chistecito
en la segunda competencia ya se movió
pero aún así sólo consiguió un sexto
lugar
y cuando iba a competir y regresaba mis
amigos me preguntaban oye venga
para qué sirve hacer robots en insumo si
no ayudan a nadie o sólo de diversión no
tenían razón pero ese comentario me hizo
recordar algo que me decía mi mamá
cuando era chico ella me decía que si no
iba a barrer que por lo menos construir
un robot que lo hiciera o uno que
pudiera regar las plantas me decía que
buscará la forma de ayudar a los demás
con las cosas que me apasionaba
y así fue como un día mientras estaba
navegando en internet y con base a esta
broma que más llama
encontrar la inspiración de lo que
comenzó un proyecto llamado vio a
es una prótesis que tiene la capacidad
de poder abrir y cerrar cada dedo de
manera independiente por medio un sensor
mío eléctrico un sensor que se encarga
de amplificar los impulsos eléctricos en
nuestro cuerpo para poder leerlos y con
estos saber cuándo abrir y cerrar la
mano
pero funciona con cables estos en un
gran inconveniente ya que estorbaba y
pues no se veían bien pero así es como
había construido la primera prótesis
después la segunda versión de esta
prótesis comenzó cuando un día mientras
estaba viendo relojes inteligentes
pensión increíble que sería que ese
reloj pudiera estar incrustado en mi
antebrazo todo el tiempo se imagina que
pudiera decir mi ritmo cardíaco estado
de salud general la hora o que inclusive
me pudiera poner a jugar a vivir cuando
estuviera aburrido
y ahora claro que este reloj no me lo
podían cruzar al brazo pero si podía
ponerlo en la prótesis
después los cables que les mencionaba
fueron sustituidos con este brazalete
bluetooth
y así la prótesis fue mejorando poco a
poco pero aún no había un problema que
pasaba si te llamaban y no podías meter
la prótesis al bolsillo mejor en vez de
llevar la mano al celular hay que llevar
el celular a la mano y como
pues poniendo una bocina y un micrófono
en los dedos pulgar y meñique
para que de esta manera cuando recibas
una llamada la mano se ponga de esta
forma y así de fácil poder contestar
pero aún con todas estas mejoras que
poco a poco se van agregando yo les
pregunto
es la mejor prótesis o la más barata
la verdad yo creo que no
hay muchas más personas que están
desarrollando otras prótesis hechas con
piezas luego aluminio o de fibra de
carbono con una gran variedad de precios
hay algunas que se conectan directamente
al cerebro otras que son osteo
integradas lo que quiere decir que van
conectadas al esqueleto pero estas
últimas dos además de requerir
operaciones son muy costosas
una de estas prótesis la más avanzada
actualmente la desarrollo de eeuu
y su costo es nada más y nada menos que
de 11.000 dólares una cantidad que no es
posible pagar para el 95% de la
población mexicana
pero por 6000 pesos podemos desarrollar
una prótesis con características
similares y con la que inclusive puedes
ponerte a hablar con tu comadre cuando
estés aburrida
una prótesis que sea más que un pedazo
de plástico algo que las personas puedan
hacer suyo y adaptarlo a sus necesidades
todas estas prótesis que les menciono
aun con las diferencias técnicas y
económicas que puedan tener comparten
algo en común
una sola cosa
ayudar al fin y al cabo ese es el
verdadero objetivo de la tecnología no
importa cuál sea la mejor
si cada prótesis puede ayudar tan solo a
una mil oa más habrá logrado su
verdadero objetivo ayudar y hacer la
vida más fácil a las personas
pero todo esto porque en méxico no
desarrollamos robots o prótesis como en
europa japón o eeuu
si tenemos tanto talento y capacidad
como ellos muchas veces mil cosas
sobresalido y se ha posicionado en los
primeros lugares en concursos de robots
internacional cuántas veces no hemos
escuchado en la radio o televisión que
está la escuela gana campeonato de
robótica o que otros alumnos están
haciendo unas inteligente para personas
con discapacidades cosas similares las
escuchamos a diario pero no le damos
tanta importancia como no era penal en
aquel partido contra holanda durante el
mundial de 2014
y aún hay gente que lo sigue recordando
necesitamos que este tipo de proyectos
cuenten con el apoyo de nuestra sociedad
para poder desarrollarse porque si no
seguimos teniendo una inmensa fuga de
cerebros mexicanos que emigran a otros
países en busca de mejores oportunidades
para llevar a la realidad sus inventos
esto lo podemos observar en el momento
en el que una escuela de tan sólo 11.000
estudiantes como lo es el lema te genera
más patentes anualmente que todo méxico
es por eso que hice esta prótesis
porque creo en la capacidad que tenemos
todos nosotros para ayudar a los demás
con las cosas que nos apasionan
en poder desarrollar tecnología que
pueda cambiar el mundo
pero si les soy sincero
esta prótesis no comenzó cuando me di la
idea en internet
comenzó cuando desarme mi carrito a los
6 años
cuando explotó el led cuando estaba toda
la noche
armando mis robots de combate
todos esos momentos en los que disfrutar
a inventar ayudar con las cosas que
hacía pero sobre todo lograrlas hacer
funcionar sin que se prendan o exploten
porque como decía el gran nikola tesla
no creo que haya alguna emoción más
intensa para un inventor
algunas de sus creaciones funcional
esa emoción así que no se olvida de
comer de dormir de todo
y si algo he aprendido durante mi vida
es que no hay que tenerle miedo a la
curiosidad mejor pregúntese cómo
funciona todo desarma en las cosas
y con esas piezas comiencen a armar un
mejor futuro
por qué no
arranque en los motores de sus carritos
eso puede dejarlo sin juguetes o puede
llevarlos a crear el siguiente invento
del siglo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]